So, what happens if we take this big HTML input
and run it through our simplification procedure?
Let's find this out. We click on "Run."
You see that the simplification algorithm correctly returns select,
which actually means that it has been able to very nicely simplify this complex input
into just these eight characters.
Let's take a look into how this actually operates.
I'm inserting a print statement in here, which gives us a representation of the string
as well as it's length,
so we can see whatever simplify has been working on
and down here we can see how simplify() operates.
It first takes the entire string,
then it takes the first half, tests this, fails again.
Of this it takes the first half, fails again.
Takes the first half, fails again, and there we go.
With a technique like this, we can automatically simplify any input.
All we need is an automated test that tells us whether the program in question
passes or fails.
Unfortunately, at this point our strategy is not yet perfect.
We'll have to refine it a bit, because it doesn't work well for all inputs.
What happens if we put in another HTML input--that is select, foo, and end of select?
What do we get as a simplified input with this function?
So, here's our quiz. What's the result of simplify() here?
With this input: foo
Is it a string consisting out of the eight characters ?
Is it a string consisting of and the first two characters of foo?
Is it a string consisting of and all of foo?
Or is it the entire HTML input? Over to you.